at what Twitter has done to elon's life
Elon used to be a friend you know he's
somebody I knew reasonably well you his
engagement with Twitter has been
catastrophic for him as a person from my
point of view his use of it has been so
irresponsible I'm just talking about the
way he has personally used it as a user
of the platform and the way he's
interacted with people and boosted
signal boosted massively the profiles of
anonymous Q andon lunatic trolls he's
been completely Cavalier in who he
interacts with all the while knowing
that anyone he boosts suddenly gets you
know a million followers and has a
platform that they otherwise couldn't
imagine Happ I think it's a pretty dim
view to say he bought Twitter because he
was addicted to Twitter like he just
bought a little toy he bought something
that is allowing us to see more truth
but I think a certain set of people who
really believe in the system they don't
want that much truth out there right
they don't want that many voices out
there